la base une photo que trop fait j'ai
accusé d'hypocrisie de bien pire encore
le ministre de l'éducation jean françois
roberge publierait de nouveau malgré
tout sa photo en compagnie de la
pakistanaise
malalai ou chapdeuil sur twitter demain
matin moi j'étais très content de
rencontrer mal à l'ass et prix nobel de
la paix tant qu'à moi c'est un prix
nobel l'éducation son combat pour la
laïcité son combat pour l'accès des
jeunes filles à l'éducation pour le
développement international après avoir
croisé la prix nobel de la paix la
réunion des ministres de l'éducation du
g7 il écrit dans son tweet avoir discuté
d'accès à l'éducation avec celle qui a
milité au péril de sa vie contre
l'interdiction de la scolarisation des
filles par les talibans des internautes
outrés ont répliqué que le ministre a
été malhonnête que mal à la voile et ne
pourrait pas enseigner au québec avec la
loi interdisant enseignants le port de
signes religieux sort ces pauvres est si
mal avoue l'enseigné au québec
d'abord au cégep et à l'université la
loi ne s'applique pas dans ce sens là
profs de cégep et de l'université
pourrait très bien ses nuits en portant
un symbole religieux
je pense que mal à la 6è l'enseignant
québec ce serait probablement dans ce
chef dans une université
ensuite des gens qui portent des signes
religieux qu'il enlève pendant leurs
heures de travail
ça se peut mais comprenez vous pourquoi
les gens ont réagi de cette façon au oui
parce qu'ils ont voulu instrumentaliser
une photo de ministre avec quelqu'un qui
porte un signe religieux
pour moi c'est vraiment une à marianne
douteux vraiment douteux moi je vous dis
je vais apprendre d'autres photos avec
des gens qui bordaient single jugé pas
de problème avec ça
jean françois roberge préfère retenir de
ces missions en france l'appel à une
éducation de qualité dès le plus jeune
âge
tous les pays du g7 sans aucune
hésitation reconnaissait que la science
prouve que la meilleure façon de lutter
contre les inégalités la même façon le
nez les jeunes aura lieu ces scolaires
c'est l'éducation au passage un milliard
en a pas on serait mouton noir on serait
les cancres le programme controversé des
maternelles quatre ans au québec
susciterait de l'intérêt tous vont dans
la même direction
mais l'idée d'avoir des duos enseignants
éducatrice l'idée d'avoir un cycle
intégré d'un curriculum 4 en cinq ans
c'est quelque chose qui inspire les
autres pays les vents contraires
soufflent fort mais le ministre roberge
refuse de céder quoi que ce soit
s'estimant porté par l'appui de la
majorité ici mathieu dion radio canada
montréal